well I'm scarred for life sis's to go
stare at a wall and rethink everything
uh with that said this is the
inconveniencing and by the way I
realized I forgot to mention what the
message was in the last one and it's at
it the only reason I bring it up is
actually is an interesting one it's a
Carla why don't you call me which is
like okay whatever but Carla actually is
a character mentioned later so oh it's
just interesting that they mention it
now and she's not like envision either
like a major character which is why it's
just weird um but for those who know I
won't give it away but maybe was the
creator just talking a car could be
maybe it's just two people named Carla
that they have a navigator named or
maybe he really could go through a break
oh we know uh no this one is uh on words
a Oshima IO Shima what if that dolphin
thing with the Hat uh which is like
visual greatest creation ever um so okay
uh this is an episode where dipper lies
about his age like hang out with Wendy
and her friends um in their gang of
stereotypes yeah pretty much
um and they go into this closed down
convenience store where apparently this
murder happened of the owners and but
it's haunted and all sorts of weird
stuff starts happening and the only way
to stop the ghost is to reveal he's
actually not a teenager and he
instituted this really ridiculous sheep
dance that seems to satisfy the ghosts
at the end Wendy doesn't give away that
he had to do the dance and they still
keep a little bit of a friendly
relationship together yes and that entry
comes back to uh and yeah the place is
still haunted but at least eight no they
still hate teens guys yeah um so the
poor teenage soul that walks into that
convenience store after that so yeah the
only other thing I know is it turns like
a little Easter Egg except their names
are literally MA and pas I thought that
was funny like a mob paws store um but
yeah this is definitely just like that
rap music kills them yeah it's a cool
words bellman tuck
your shirt isn't cool they died
um the Disney a-- strap song ever made
yes so that isn't i'm saying anyway that
there's one thing about this show and i
was gonna sound insulting what soviet
but i'm like caged I just look at him
like man shows too good for Disney
it's like gargoyles it's kind of like
you see the name Disney attached to it
and you're just like oh yeah did I
forget that like did Disney's getting a
lot better they are I mean but they're
always gonna be schizophrenic cuz
there's always gonna be really just the
bad Disney Channel stuff and then you
get and then you get shows like this and
it's just like wow like I wouldn't have
guessed like if you took the word Disney
off this I would never associate this
with Disney Nemo yeah I feel like
they're going through some sort of
metamorphosis right now of like really
legitimately good smart stuff and maybe
I don't know this other generation is
coming in taking over me they're just
becoming more lenient or I don't know
but they don't seem as like there's
always gonna be the tyrannical overlord
ish thing but at the thing but at the
same time they seem much more lenient
and much more accepting of the
creativity and the humor again well I
guess better to make pop itself I guess
technically they're running us and we're
still here so yes
so I'll say you see a cancel sign oh but
I think Disney's great nothing wrong
with me at all
that's right so cheese for you so but
but no I I will get like the past two
years especially it just seems like
something happen like I said with like
wreckit-ralph worsen a grab me more very
much in that we're in that Little
Mermaid to beauty and the beast'
territory yeah kind of feels that way
cuz we hit a wall for the past few years
I guess he does honestly I mean like
after Disney company any company does
yeah and any and TV doesn't like I watch
anime all the time like I watch been
watching anime for like 15 years now and
you'll always get some years where
you're just like man there's really
nothing good out and then you'll get
some years where it's like holy crap
you'll get three years in a row with all
these amazing shows is
everything comes in cycles and in
Hollywood movies and Disney was the same
they they had you know their 80s stuff
was kind of dark and gritty but after
Disney died you could tell there was
this really confused slump on being a
point where they were going or what they
want to do in the 80s was sort of fun
for me because it was kind of
experimenting you got some weird dark
gritty shit not always good but and then
yeah they hit like Little Mermaid Beauty
and the Beast the Disney Afternoon and
around the same time started kicking in
ducktales and I started gummi bears
again yeah and like really did for what
I kept that going Ted we at paise are 90
step about 96 when Pixar rose as Disney
was an era which I mean I know they were
owned by the same people at the time but
you know the different divisions of
labor like obviously Pixar got really
hot shit and Disney started falling and
now I'm not saying Pixar is falling
they've had a couple ones that didn't
impressive it but Disney's definitely
back on the rise yeah and like this to
me is like more evidence of it um so
it's a fun episode I think the only way
I can figure out the gateway with a lot
of this stuff is that they do so
emphasize these morals have always tell
the truth always be true tear so yes are
the traditional Disney morals um it's
like Animaniacs so I think some of its
just under the radar yeah it could be -
a lot of the jokes I'm just like yeah
they're bad if you think about it but
they kind of just come and go so quickly
that you have to have like a sick mind
and yeah they don't pull it too much
focus on I mean it's made for us we just
insulated just like yeah but do a kid it
could go right over there yeah or it
could be one of those things like it's
trying to appeal to people our age you
may end up having to watch this with
their own children yeah I are those
jokes are funny but you know what you
know what I like they're not ah what am
I looking for they're not hip cultural
jokes they they sort of retro yeah it's
not but it's they're not they're retro
jokes but they don't see manufactured
it's I'm honest no it's it's not dated
like everything tries so hard to be hip
that it just almost seems dated because
you're like oh yeah like 90s I can this
this doesn't there are some things that
make it a little dated but like the
style of the jokes doesn't seem that
date yeah it seems prey pad again very
much I get venture time where these like
I could want
time I feel like I could watch us 20
years from now and while I'd be like
okay yeah that's yeah I can manage and
Millennials and I still would be like
you know what this still holds up like
it's still legitimately funny even
though some of the little things are
dated but like some cartoon shows i
watch nowadays I'm just like oh man this
is just painful like yeah I thought this
was cool when I was 10 but now I'm
saying oh this is such a 90s kid kinda
like it was like oh but yeah in terms of
the interesting episode itself um it's
the first episode we have more of an
emphasis on Wendy and sort of what she's
all about um and and yeah this is where
we can sort of talk about her a little
bit more I mean the characters there's
nothing wrong with her per se um but it
is very obviously like oh love interest
like you're gonna be the love interest
and the only character to me that's more
annoying than the one who's obviously
just a love interest is the one who's
obviously the third part of the love
triangle in the love oh my god Bobby
character definitely insulted because
his name is Robbie he's a totally
hanging douche by hate the Robbie
character not because you're supposed to
hate that it's because he's that's the
only reason he's there and he's poorly
written uninteresting the wad not even a
good design not really even a good tooth
it I don't like my problem Wendy's I
feel like she's some sort of hipster
millennial creation like the chart said
throw in a character like this that's it
I don't find the character really
offensive and in-your-face like I've
seen worse but it's not a character I'm
like I'm gripped like the two kids I
could watch all day know best and I can
watch Wendy's just like yeah here's a
random teenage character that appeals to
this demogroup but her friends though
just like I just get bored like whenever
they're on screen like none of them at
least yet seem I think the most
interesting moment is the fat guy doing
the dance here right yeah just so you
know uh my mother was saying don't you
know heard putzie Lee say a bunch of CS
I've got the important suet but you know
it's like I just like heck - boats yeah
I but otherwise the rest of the friends
pretty boring yeah um if they don't come
back the way life comes back is Robbie
who of course it's like the most
irritating
I remember like the video game episode
is the one you showed me yeah and he's
aided him in that but then again there's
kind of like a catharsis an episode with
him I will say like he comes back a few
times but it's not like not to a point
it's like I think they get the idea it's
like okay let's let him and they sort of
uh get out of them bad no that's the
only part of the show so far that seems
weak to me that's where I start to you
know like there's always the invisible
hand that controls everything like in
shows and when the invisible hand
becomes visible and you're just like oh
like you know somebody wanted to appeal
to this demographic or marketing isn't
like I don't get a lot of it except with
those set like Wendy and her friends I'm
just like yeah this is the weaker part
of the show for me it could be to that
there is a Zelman a they were saying hey
play with you know dipper wanting to be
part of the crowd stuff like that so the
probably okay well what are teenagers
doing now and this is you know an older
generation trying to look at okay what
are they kind of about and doing when I
say might being the funniest stuff with
Wendy is when she is you know very much
sort of that frat girl thing that you
know it's just like hey you know hey
it's off the chain and stuff like she'll
suddenly do like this weird voice or
just like cheer something really stupid
it's like see to me or that line at the
end it's like well I think I'm scarred
for life I'm just gonna look at a wall
and rethink everything so anyway yeah
blah blah blah and it's just like
totally forgotten me you know it's you
know seems like that I think make her a
lot of fun if there are there's a few
times in the future where it's like she
does a legitimately cool badass thing
but I feel like it's one of those things
like I always find it interesting that
somehow you can write timeless
children's characters but when it comes
to teenagers that's always where people
get tripped up like if they had to write
like current ones and teenagers are so
much about like what is popular now and
it's hard yeah up kids but the thing is
I'm not convinced that you necessarily
have to do I think it's a problem just
like trying too hard
I'm not convinced that you have to do
that like you could just write teenage
characters without having to get so
sucked up in the current climate I don't
know well I mean fuck do I know about
teenagers I don't know what I'm talking
come on out of high school for more than
15 years uh no but there's something to
that there are some things that never
really do change with you know teenage
characters you know even the joke about
you you know the pale skin and bad
attitude you know they often confuse for
teenagers it's like yeah it's never
gonna change
you know ya know like I liked those
jokes so I I don't know it's the only
thing that's weird but yeah but even
then it's not like oh I can't watch it I
mean it's just like you said yeah no I
I still watch this episode and I thought
it was hilarious yeah the sugar the
sugar rush yes that's the best part that
eating the ham oh my god
oh that design of the yeah but that was
when the greatest was adult film Italian
Affairs coming out I am so shocked
sci-fi did not take one look at that and
be like find a way to rip that off
sci-fi movie of the week um so that
blows things I've seen on Cartoon
Network out of the water for purists or
reality I was genius um yeah and I think
the only other thing I can think of
before signing off is that I do serve
like that I think most kids or teens
whatever at some point have that
encounter where it's like you go
someplace you're not supposed to late at
night break it just because you can and
you do whatever stupid thing you can
think of but because it's against the
rule it's amazing you know so I don't
people kill home would speak yeah yeah
what I anyway well the other thing I
liked about this episode was uh
it's legitimately scary yeah I love we
look in the reflection with the skeleton
yeah this one in particular a little
more scary than some of the other ones
like I don't know if this was a
Halloween episode of there's anything
special better and just happen to be
scarier but I really like that like have
a Ghostbusters feel like yeah I guess is
also legitimately yes legitimate a
spooky I mean I was never like scared
scared but I'm like you know if I were a
kid that be watching this episode a
little bit like okay so the sign turning
around clothes I mean yeah those little
touches I mean you know do add up um so
no good episode and we will see you in
episode I think 6 6 5 or is it 5
I think it 606 yeah I realize it were
marathoning me someone who's in charge
hey come on you know the drill little up
to six six oh yeah six six is good six
just six good yeah so nice talking with
your Wayne you get it
don't act like you don't it's Tim
Burton's Batman with that I think we
need our girly scream no